o pessoal seja 21 mais um vídeo e hoje
vou ensinar como fazer um carrinho e
usando materiais de fácil acesso e
funciona quase como se fosse um carrinho
é que acho que vocês compram nas lojas
a grande diferença é que eu tenho um
carro então vocês têm que andar atrás
dele
aí eu espero que vocês façam isso correm
comigo e com mais alguém pegue o vosso
pai nossa mãe nossa voz não tenho vocês
quiserem partilhar o momento esse e
agora vamos meter mãos à obra
vai lá para começar vou precisar de
comprar o cartão de uma caixa que vocês
não precisem um lápis e uns quadro
coloca em pauta em estampar e depois qo
pinho desânimo para o vosso cartão
[Música]
o corte de 10 x ato e uma base para
curtir a mesa se forem crianças peçam
ajuda o duto que sim vai ser muito mais
divertido e seguro para vocês
contorne peça que vocês fizeram em cima
de um pedaço de cartão concordem esta
também e depois correm as duas partes
[Música]
porém quatro tampas guerra franco
utilizando uma figura da era se não
tiverem podem utilizar um objeto afiado
o loc um bico no centro eo jovem até que
for com linhas quatro tampas de forma a
formar duas rodas segura na posição
certa até que a escola cepe
[Música]
para fazer esse projeto vamos precisar
de dois motores e do puma curia euro ter
estas coisas de dvds players
porém se vocês não tiverem em casa é só
ir a uma loja de informática e plantar
porque aumentamos tem essas coisas num
canto e mandou pro lixo normalmente
[Música]
como a senhora para tal quarta em dois
hospitais de caneta com três centímetros
de comprimento
[Música]
a marca uma linha 4 centímetros da
traseira e depois cole um pedaço caneta
[Música]
a descolar o segundo turno coloque um
palito de churrasco é pública acumulada
no meio de um elástico a volta e sim
podem colar é a segunda parte
[Música]
quarta em um planeta de forma que sabe
mais ou menos 3 no limite para fora e aí
sim podem colar o eixo as rodas mas em
duas bolas madeira e colegas
participantes uma contra a outra como
vocês estão vendo aqui agora vejam
calculando as duas partes da bola
criamos um furo
temos que criar outro porém este quem
ficar no grupo índico lar marca e fúria
em 2001 fora dela
[Música]
na quarta o chefe do zero uma serra para
metal
[Música]
no vídeo os políticos têm dimensões
ligeiramente frente por aí o conseg que
vocês colocam questões com 4,5
centímetros para evitar erros que eu já
estou aqui a prover e coloquem pois é
que um pedaço de caneta com mais ou
menos 34 milímetros de altura uma rosa e
depois um pedaço de político com forno
centro para travar a roda para que ela
não saia 2
[Música]
quando um político com furos na
extremidade e essa distância seja a
distância entre os furos é de 6,6
sentindo
entre os furtos caiu um palito dos lado
marca em dois pontos é três centímetros
de distância
contorna volta recordem ea desfazer os
furos é muito importante colocar em
super cola na extremidade
desta forma o pagamento vai aguentar um
furo ou seja quando fizer aquela opção
eu não vai arrebentar passa em um
planeta do conjunto das rodas pelo furo
depois coloque um pedaço caneta com
altura de um motor que vocês utilizarem
na parte da frente o carrinho e por fim
coloque o pânico fizeram anteriormente e
cola em dois anos super cola
agora é muito importante que esta parte
se mova cair se consiga rodar por um
lado e para o outro
depois de fazer a mesma coisa para o
outro lado ou seja para outra roda este
talento tem furos na extremidade que
estão a 6,6 centímetros de distância e
tem outro furo no centro de seguida eu
coloquei dois palitos de churrasco 1,5
centímetros nos fúria das extremidades e
colégio usando super cola depois prender
uma peça de forma conectar as duas rodas
e prendam com dois círculos da madeira
para ela não sair do sítio e para ficar
melhor empresa coloque uma gota de cola
em queda bonito soldar é opcional por
encomendas porque desta forma os carros
ficam muito bem preso
agora se vocês não tiverem ofertas volta
em casa não vão comprar de propósito
para fazer projetos podem lavar os fios
muito banho linhos e provavelmente não
vai acontecer se nada de muito traje de
cinco anos que já vai poder um pouco
contacto mas depois volta se abanar
nunca vi o vosso brinquedo
como vocês acabaram de ver qo sair o
motor na parte da frente no proibido que
fica entre as rodas e o segundo motor
vou colocar aqui forma que o eixo deu
fica alinhado com a policia do trecho já
podia das rotas de trás quando esta
colas carvão colocar mais por cima do
motor para explicar para a empresa e
agora voltar pra ver se isso funciona
a senhora é e agora vou colar uma mola
numa lateral do carrinho e outra do
outro lado é isso aqui vai ser muito
importante para nós prendemos o elástico
e e silagem quando tivesse ficado entre
estas duas molas vai fazer com carrinho
ando direito ou seja as lojas fiquem é
alinhado às coisas de trás e só visar
que em breve segundo será ocorrer uma
tentativa de marketing uma pessoa vai
tentar impingir vos um produto só que
não correu muito bem e opções estão
esqueceu se de dizer que o conjunto
custa menos de 20 euros
sei que agora neste momento você afonso
bento cismados e que só querem ter
publicidade então em 321 vai publicidade
só assim este é um livro e 15 em fazer
dez projetos diferentes
e para tornar as coisas mais fáceis e
fiz esta parte aqui que traz um material
ea foi para a queda projeto que esta que
estou aqui
depois é feita uma troca entre os dentes
ou seja se vocês quiserem usar isso para
guardar as boas coisas qual podem fazer
isso agora está um especial de natal
então se vocês tiverem prestado explica
que o primeiro nunca esqueçam lá vocês
conseguem ler algumas páginas do livro
escutarem completava daqui pra não ficar
feio pra você que acha que não é hora de
fazer o comando do nosso carinho para
isso coloque em pausa com fizeram na
parte inicial do vídeo e usando os quase
um lápis culpe o design por um pedaço de
cartão
a record tem e depois façam três cópias
do que vocês fizeram anteriormente
colhem as placas 2002
corta uma faixa com dois tentos de
largura e tenham atenção à orientação
dos canudos do cartão cair
se cortarmos desta forma depois
conseguimos facilmente dar uma direção à
faixa de seguida contou nem a placa
utilizando faixa e atenção não tenham
pressa vamos colocando aos poucos perdem
sexo e depois avancem para o próximo das
quer dizer não é bom em toda a volta tem
uma pequena para que não tem nada eu
estou fazendo gols para colocar a
bateria de 9 volts e desta forma nós
mal-estar podemos retirá lo e substituí
la por uma nova
[Música]
quarta em política com sentido do
comprimento e depois cola entre dois
planetas inteiros de forma que as
extremidades se encontra em um dos lados
[Música]
marca em oito centímetros e faça uma
linha inclinada para o lado mais com
perigo para as peças estão vendo lado
direito e depois cola e nem usando super
cola e não vou mostrar como fazer as
peças da direita por vocês já viram
outras muito parecidas serem feitas
antes e não gostar para não repetir
muito
usando uma furadeira o então objeto
afiado como um palito de churrasco
faça um furo no meio dessa linha de
forma que passa por todas as camadas
corta um pleito com mais ou menos altura
do comando
depois coloque um pedaço tema da idéia
se um círculo da madeira e empurram para
cima mais ou menos cinco milímetros e
por fim colo em um buraco quando a
colocar coloquei peça que fizeram
anteriormente no vale tudo
[Música]
nós vamos conseguir controlar esse
carinho perdendo popularidade ou seja
quando nós invertemos a prioridade
invertemos a direção em como torre gira
nós temos uma bateria que tem um lado
positivo o lado negativo e ligamos a
motor
agora quando nós invertemos os cabos na
bateria seja os tapas e eu passamos para
negativo está negativo para positivo
nós mudamos a direção encontrou gira e
que estou a fazer um teste para saber
como ligar os cabos corretamente
agora se você se enganarem mais tarde
não tem problema corta um carro e depois
inverte se vocês tiverem memória como eu
podem fazer uma pequena anotação dentro
do comando e não tem problema uma vez
que não se vai ver vai ficar tapado no
final e de seguida vocês passem os
veremos por dentro os furos collins anos
super cola e é muito importante que
estejamos fiquem em paralelo vai
acontecer com uma ideia para travar esta
peça que não sei bem como chamá lo é um
é algo que tem uma para tem folga é não
sei dizer
com uma tampa de uma garrafa de um litro
e meio de água dentro de uma tampa de um
garrafão de cinco litros e depois vocês
têm que fazer cinco furos um furo tem
que ser um centro e pois tem outros
quatro que têm ficar basicamente virados
um com o outro não sabem como explicar
isso seja tem que haver uma continuidade
de um furo para outros nós olharmos por
dentro de um furo conseguimos ver o
outro foram basicamente isso e assim
podemos passar as coisas pelos dois for
por exemplo de 20 anos aqui e agora
vamos testar a popularidade como fizemos
anteriormente e como vocês podem ver eu
acertei a primeira mas não tivesse
acertado era só tirar os arames e
inverteu sul
a rosinha que vamos fazer vai ficar
dentro do nosso comando não vai ficar
visível porque nós precisamos duma que
fique no exterior para nós conseguimos
dar a direção do nosso carrinho para
fazermos esta vamos precisar de duas
tampas outra vez uma grande outra menina
vamos furar a pequenina ou maio e depois
vamos colocar lá dentro da tampa grande
desta vez virado ao contrário não for
não é como antes e por fim vamos colar
um palito com quatro centímetros de
comprimento como prioridade a foi
detectada então eu agora sim posso
calcular estas partes cederam a tampa ou
tampas são dois colares
coloque a tampa teste 20 anos mais ou
menos nesta posição e depois faça um
furo usando a outra tampa que tenha que
o pânico disputado depois fazer um furo
é só passar a tampa pelo outro lado e
depois colar com muita cola
[Música]
prenda um elástico o nosso céu de forma
que quando nós não tocarmos neo eu fico
naturalmente no centro do nosso comando
e assim nós podemos
michel para um lado e para o outro para
ser mais fácil fazermos as conexões dos
cabos decide cortar isso em três partes
e vamos cortar este mais ou menos assim
o olho e primeiro veicular as partes
pequeninas e depois fazemos as conexões
assim mais importante é que muscular a
outra parte
[Música]
muita atenção nesta partida vamos
começar por colocar 1 hora no centro de
forma que fique a meio da forca
depois vamos movimentar a fofoca para um
dos lados e colocar outra de forma que a
forca toca nos dois éramos conosco no
campus
em seguida vamos movimentar à forca para
o outro lado e colocar o outro é o toque
também na forca ou seja sempre que nós
movimentamos por um lado a força toca em
dois anos e por outro lado o mesmo
acontece quando estiver tudo certo aí
sim vocês podem colocar uma gota de cola
para que a galera tem que fazer o mesmo
para robinho que tem os 20 anos
o princípio eu mesmo acho que nem sei
explicar muito mais aqui tem que tocar
um lado e tem que ficar do outro lado
depois de colocarem usaremos todo
circularem com super-cola aí sim vocês
podem fechar o comando e tenham atenção
que tenha que o furo na peça que vocês
vão pular que tem que encaixar no que o
clube tinha o'leary que é o eixo do
nosso é o conforto fez história aqui
para vocês perceberem mais facilmente
como ligarem os cabos é bastante simples
olhando aqui para o desânimo a e plantei
isso é só ligar os cabos da forma que
você estamos ser
[Música]
fiz um conector para a bateria do novo
volte usando um mapa triângulo ou seja
uma bateria descarregada é só vocês
arrancarem com muito cuidado a parte de
cima usando um alicate
depois foi só saudar os cabos em cada
terminal do conector já estamos com as
causas que geram final só falta mesmo
saudar os fios aos arames e uma coisa
que eu fiz e novos mostrei que que
basicamente o cara rouba muito então eu
curta em uma faixa com 1,5 centímetros
de tva e cuba ea volta de cada roda isso
resolver o meu problema né isso é
bastante simples é quando você não está
aqui só cortar a faixa e claro a volta
das obras
[Música]
ah mas eu to aqui só se houvesse
importado ficou livre fiquei aqui
chegamos ao fim só espero que vocês
tenham gostado de ver algumas estão
deixando os comentários a isso dá adeus
à tona
já o everton neste a